au chapitre de la médecine une étape
très importante vers le traitement des
myopathies suit l'équipe américaine
vient de guérir pour la première fois
des animaux myopathe alors ces travaux
sont publiés dans la revue nature
alors bien sûr on est encore très loin
de l'application à l'homme mais
l'échéance se rapproche un peu plus
chaque jour jean daniel flaysakier c'est
dur à croire mais ces souris sont mis
aux pattes et si elles vont mieux c'est
qu'elles bénéficient des traitements que
les chercheurs tentent de mettre au
point pour guérir la maladie chez
l'homme en effet pour qu'un muscle
fonctionne normalement il faut qu'ils
possèdent une substance que l'on appelle
la dystrophine voilà sous un microscope
à quoi ressemble le muscle normal et
voilà où se trouve la dystrophine mais
quand le gène de la dystrophine n'est
plus là quand on ne peut plus fabriquer
ce produit
le muscle prend cet aspect et va mourir
peu à peu c'est ce qui se passe dans les
myopathies puis une équipe américaine
vient de marquer un point essentiel dans
la recherche contre les myopathies
les chercheurs ont en effet introduit le
gène de la dystrophine dans un embryon
de souriceaux toutes les petites souris
nés après cette manipulation sont
normales en quelque sorte guéri de la
myopathie
il est techniquement impossible de
réaliser la même manipulation sont des
embryons humains mais ses résultats sont
suffisamment importants pour que les
chercheurs et chaud au coeur
je crois qu'on a dépassé l'aube de la
démonstration que l'on pourrait guérir
les maladies musculaires congénitales ce
ne sera pas facile mais la preuve de la
faisabilité a été apportée certainement
chez l'homme en utilisant une méthode
différente on introduira le gène de la
dystrophine dans un virus rendu
inoffensif et l'ensemble virus plus
jeune sera injectée soit directement
dans les muscles malades soit peut-être
par voie sanguine afin que tout cela sud
dissémine dans tout l'organisme
l'évaluation des premiers résultats est
très satisfaisante
si bien que dans les mois qui viennent
et au plus tard pour le prochain
téléthon en décembre les myopathes et
leurs familles devraient entendre dès
nouvelle très encourageante